よろしくお願いします
えーと 前置きは要りませんね
まあ今日今から仏教の話をしますとか
えーと 今日のテーマはこの何でしたっけ？慢ということで
慢との付き合い方 で これ慢というのはなかなか消えないもので
まあ 3種類ありますけどね
高慢 髭慢 盗盗慢とかね
まあこれ一般的に 3種類ですけど
まだたくさんありますが
まあ今日はそこら辺は全部カットしました
一体慢って何かと まあ勉強してみましょう
で 慢という言葉の意味ですね
最初に パーリ語でマーナというんですね
あの このパーリ語のマーナは
このサンスクリット語のマーナは
ただダジャレで慢にしたではないと思いますが
よくわからないんで なんか似ていますけど
まあおそらく ん？この言語の言葉の意味はね
あの これははっきりしないということで
まあ自分の意見ですから
この前にそういう数学の際に入れましたけど
測る まあという動詞からね
測るというのはサンスクリット
パーリ語でマンという語根ですね
その語根から まあ語根はそんなにたくさんないんですけどね
そこからは無数の単語を作るんですね
で 作ったと思います 常に測ってみる性格という意味で
慢というのは測るということなんですね
そこで常に測ってみる性格ということを表すために
マーナという風にしたんじゃないかなと思います
もう一つ 経典から経典を見ると
経典はね 別に言語学にはそんなにこだわらないんだからね
別な意味でも解説は見つかりましたけど
まあこれ専門的な講義ではございませんのでね
だからまあそんなのはどうでもいいやと思ったんですね
考えるということにも慢というんですね
そこでマンニャティという妄想するという動詞がそこからできているんですね
だからマーナの同義語を書いている時は
マンニャティという言葉は当然出てくるんですね
いわゆる妄想するというね
ですから 思い思い込みという意味でマーナかもしれません
私は測るという意味で
一応こちらスライドに書きました
思い込む だからマーナというなよ
慢というのを言うんだよという定義も構わない
で それで慢という言葉からね
別な動詞から別な動詞が作れます
しかし マーネーティという動詞がありますね
マーネーティという動詞の意味は
慢を張るのではなく 尊敬するということなんです
測るということは パーリ語でミナーティというんですね
だからミナーティといえば測る
マーネーティといえば
マーナと似ているんだからということで勘違いしないでください
それは尊敬するっていう意味なんです
まあ心配しなくても どうせパーリ語読まないんだからね
間違いは犯した出家または見習い出家の戒めの行はマーナタというんですね
これもマーナに似ています
マーナに似ていますけど
間違い マーナタという行がありまして
これ出家の中で で マーナタを実況行しなくちゃいけない
まあ行ですね これは普通
出家の中で行うことでね
まあいろいろ失敗するしね
間違いもあるしね で その場合はこの何かやらせるんですね
そのやらせる まあ罰みたいなもんなんですけどね
これやらせることはマーナタというんですね
それはこの謙虚になりなさいというね
という戒め という意味で使っているんですね
仏法僧に対し 例えば自分が個人的に弱いんだから失敗しても
出家ですから これはサンガに対する侮辱だと思うんです
解説するわざと あんた個人でやったと思ったって
それは冗談じゃないやと
それは私個人の失敗だと
あんた出家に入ろうとしてるでしょ？見習いでしょうにと
あんた このサンガ組織に対して侮辱をしたんだと
ということで もっと何て言いますか
謙虚になりなさいということで
このマーナタという行を与えるんですね
まあそれは関係ない 今日は
はい テーマに入ります
じゃあマーナっていうのは
マンっていうのは測ること
測るというところ もう漢字ではいくつかの漢字が出てきましたからね
どちらか分からなくなっちゃって
まあ全部使いましたけど
まあいろいろもう 何を測るんですか？例えば米を
米を測ったりなどの必要な秤もあります
この世の中で で マナーが悪い人というのは
まあ一応前提で万が悪いという前提で喋ってます
で ああ ということは 測ることが悪いという意味になってしまいますね
まあそうでもなくて まあ測って必要なものはありますよ
万というのは自分を測ることなんですね
自分を測ってみるんです
だから決して体重には乗ってはいけないって意味ですかね
まあ体重のことじゃなくてね
まあ自分自身のね まあ存在を測ってみるんですね
この自分を測る天秤に使う
これ何でしたっけ？分銅
分銅は人間あるいは他人なんですね
あの天秤がありますね
見たことないでしょうね
今日は写真出そうと思ったんですけど
写真自体はあまりダサい写真で古い
良くないんで まあ一応あのピクセル数が良くなくて
ちょっともう映したらあまり良くないと思ったんです
あの昔の天秤みたいな秤がありまして
そこで一つの方に分銅を入れなくちゃいけないんですね
もう一人 自分が測ってほしいもの
そこで一つの方にさらに自分を入れるんです
もう一つの皿に他人を入れるんです
これはもう不確定で よくわからない
誰が入れるのかいと まあ大体人間だからね
まあまあ 人間入れるでしょうね
犬猫とかは入れないでしょうね
で 他人を入れて測るんですね
それがマナというんです
自分のエゴ 存在感を測ってみるんです
自分のエゴを測ってみるんです
自分の存在感を 一体私って何者かいと
他人と比較して測ってみるんです
それがマナというんです
分道になる 他人によって
そこでこの分道にどんな人をするかよくわからないでしょう
我々 しょっちゅう会う人と測ってみるんですね
いつでも自分に合う会う会う人と自分を測ってみるんだから
これ大変な仕事なんですよ
もうやりきれないんですね
終わりがないんです 人に会うたびにさっと秤に入れて
あ こんな程度だなとかね
すぐさっさと測るんです
ですから この自分の存在っていうのは
はい 重い 等しい 軽いという大体 ３つのカテゴリーに測って決めるんです
この重いとか だから秤を使ったんだから
この単語を使ったんだけど
別に我々は物質的な秤を使ってないんだから
ただ比較することだから
どんな単語でもいいんです
例えば自分の美を測ってみる場合はね
まあ自分より美しいとか
まあ自分と同じやと まあ大したことはないと
そういうふうに その場合は言葉が変えてもよろしい
それから自分 頭の良さも自分の存在でしょ
時々 あの人 この人はどうですかね
頭の良さはと 例えばディスカッションとか知識的なことに
もうシンポジウムやらあれやこれやでぶつかっちゃうと測るんですね
みんな その時はネクタイはどんなメーカーですかとはね
学会では全然気にもしません
あ これはブランドのネクタイですね
相当高いです それはまるっきり気にしてない
その代わりに この人の能力程度
どの程度だと そこでもう頭がいいか悪いかって測ってみるんですね
その場合は自分と測るんだから
自分が頭がいい 自分と同じ
まあ大したことはないと
いうふうに測ったりするんです
とにかく値が 3つ出ます
この値も決して一定しないんですね
だから自分という一つの品物を入れるでしょ
秤の皿に なのにもう一つの皿にも
何て言いますか 不確定多数
何て言いますか なんとか単語がありますね
不確定多数の人を入れるんだから
その都度その都度 だから自分の値はもう変わるわ
変わるわ 変わるわ キリがないんです
ですからもう例えば家の中で兄弟と家族だったら
もう人数は決まってますから
それで自分の価値はしっかりとこれっていう風に
はっかりはっきりするんですね
だからみんな家族の中にいると大体落ち着きます
測らなくてもいいんだからね
もうちゃんとバーコードで貼ってますからね
その場合は 私の価値はこれぐらいと
これで学校に行ったらすごくなんかビクビクするんですね
それでまあ大体 1週間
2週間  1ヶ月間ぐらい経ってくると
まあ測って もう不確定じゃないんだから
多数じゃないんだから
人数がね それで一旦自分の値が出てくるんです
それから学校は楽しくて落ち着くんです
しかし 人生はいつでもそういう狭い範囲で生きていられるわけでもなりません
で というわけで 私たちはずっともう測って測って測って測って
もうくたびれるんですよ
測るたびに あの 自分の値が変わるんです
で 次の問題はなんで測るんですかね
人には自我 エゴの意識はありますが
自信がなくて不安なんです
ちっちゃな子供でもすごいエゴがあるんですよ
あるんだけど どうも自信がないんですね
だから測ってみたいんです
他人と比較して測ることで
自我確立したいんです
私はこういうものだと
あれは自分の精神不安をなんとかしたいんだからやっていることなんです
測ることは しかし 測れば測るほど自我の値が変わるので
だから結果は逆になるんです
測れば測るほど自我の値が変わるんです
例えば 頭が悪い人と測ったらね
頭が悪くて大したことないと
すごい もうなんて言いますか
いい気分になるでしょ
それでちょっと左見たら別な人がいたら
まあ相当怖いんだ 頭が良くて
そうするとまた惨めになるんです
だから自我の確立したいところが値が常に変わるんだから
自我確立のつもりは限りのない自我不安という結果になってしまうんです
そこで私はこの微妙に皆様にこの生きることの矛盾ということは
ここで見えるならばありがたいんですけどね
最初からも私たちにはなんていうのは不安があるんです
不安をなくすために自我を確立したいんです
それで測ってみるんです
それで不安になるんです
これ 自分がやっているんです
どうしても測らずにいられないんですよ
生きていられないんです
それで測ってみたら 結果として生きていられなくなるんです
それで生きていられなくなっちゃうと
やっぱり測れちゃう 測るんです
測ったらまた生きていられなくなるんです
これで立派な見事なサイクルが出来上がるんです
はい 次に この自我の値ということについて勉強してみましょう
自分にどの程度の価値観があるのかと知りたいんです
どんな生命も自分にどのぐらいの価値観があるのかと
知りたくなるんですね
そうしないと不安でたまらないんです
で  自分の価値を知りたいんです
自分にどんな価値あるのかとわからないと
もう不安でしょ これ バリューオブセルフっていうんですね
自分としての価値ですね
知るために測るんです
だから この仏教用語でいうマーナっていうことはそういうことなんです
自分としての価値を知りたいんです
あれ セルフバリューではなくて
バリューオブセルフなんです
で 単語をちょっと交代すると
またすごく意味が変わるんです
これが万ということになります
自我の値とも言いましょうかね
だから万っていうのは自我の値ですね
同じテーマの続きですね
自我の値と またダブってます
人間は何にでも価値をつけたくなるんです
これは自分に対してだけではなくて
いつでも何か価値をつけきてから対応するんです
価値がわかれば対応の仕方も決めます
これ 我々の人間という生命のという基本なんですね
いつでもどんなものにも価値を入れてみる
いわゆる値札をつけるということですね
どんなものにも価値を入れる
だからどこが面白いかとわからない
もうガラクタにも時々ね
まあ一千万とか値札入れるでしょ
これでまあガラスケースの中に入れて
空気をちゃんとコントロールして
こういうもう重要博物がある美術館でガラクタありますけどね
随分金かかってますよ
あんなのはもう もう保管保存するためには
まあ例えば これは年十年前といったと
すっと価値が入っているんです
もうほとんどボロボロ
なんかまあお寺 神社とかあったという
ちょこっとしたところで
こちらはなんだらかんだら様がね
まあ千二百年のところで
ここはここでなんとか戦いでいて
ここで座って休みになり
お休みになったところだと
そこであの梅干しとおにぎりを食べましたと
それで価値を入れて そちらは梅干し神社ができちゃって
そこではもういろんなレストランで
そのなんとか様が食べた
もうご飯がと もうおにぎりはこんなもんでしたとかね
いろんなものを作ったりして
まあ大変大騒ぎはします
で そのようにもう何に価値入れたところで対応の仕方が見えてくるんです
うん まあそういう人生ですね
結局は 例えば何の価値もないとゼロ価値やと思ったところでも
無関心 例えば皆様どこそこら辺でね
百万ペソのあの 紙幣って言うんですか？この
何見つかる？なんだ なんか面白い紙だなとかね
なんかどこかの国の金みたいなとかね
しかし あまり価値入れてないんですね
そこで百万ペソじゃなくて百万
百万ではなくて百 間違った
百ペソのなんとか それで百ペソじゃなくて百ドルの紙を見つけたらどうします？まあ
びっくりですね でも同じ大きさの紙なんですけど
それで印刷で技術的に言えば
だから百万ペソの紙の方が結構色もあって
頑張って印刷しています
百ドルの紙っていうのは
もうこいつら技術能力っていうのはゼロかい？と聞きたいぐらい
あまりにもシンプルなんです
色もそんなにかっこいいわけじゃないし
しかし 足が止まりますね
だから私たちの態度がこの価値によって変わるんです
はい それってね 別に まあ例えばただのラクーンでしたっけね
まあパンダがいるんですね
パンダは見ただけでまあびっくり
感動してパンダのぬいぐるみまでね
すごいでしょうに でも同じ種類の動物は皆様もここ東京に見るんで
あっちこっちで 何て言いますか
英語でラクーンと言うんですけど
あの タヌキじゃなくてもう一ついますね
タヌキじゃなくてもあっちこっちいるんですね
東京の最近なんかいろんなところで
あ ではないです  タヌキは人間見たら逃げるでしょ
人間から餌をもらったりもするしね
同じ種類なんですけど
まあ結構いますけど で
それ全然価値入れてないんですね
で なんでどうったことはないパンダにって
あれは価値によってパンダに対する対応が随分違います
動物のパンダを見るためにはちゃんと並んでいなくちゃいけないし
防弾ガラスみたいなところでね
まあしっかりしているし
近寄ることはさせないし
まあ大変ですよ この価値を入れることで執着の強度を決めるんです
この床に落ちているのはガラスの破片かダイヤかということで
ガラスの破片だったら
まあ 0 価値でもなくマイナス価値で
で マイナス価値の場合も動くんですね
あ これはもう早くも処分しなくちゃいけないと
え？これはガラスの破片じゃないんですよ
これダイヤだとわかったら
また別な態度するんですね
で そういうことで この何て言いますか
執着の強度 どんな程度執着すればよろしいかとと思うんです
この執着するのは この価値を入れた時なんです
だから価値はプラスであろうとも
マイナスであろうとも執着になるんです
どちらでも執着なんですね
例えば自分の家になんかもう迷子になって
あるいはまあ 何て言いますか
捨てた猫がいて すごい可愛い捨てた猫ですけど
勝手に来て自分のところにニャンニャンと鳴き
ながらね 体に体を削ったりすると
なんで可愛い猫ちゃんですか？とかわいそうに捨てられたよと
首輪もないとかね それでプラス価値を入れるんですね
それでじゃあ買ってあげようかなと
そこで猫は家にいるよとドアを開けているところで
自分がもうちょっと見なかったんですけど
ヘビも 1匹入ってきたとしましょう
日本でよくあるヘビ 何でしたっけ？なんとかヘビがいるんですね
マムシ で ヘビはああやって見えませんね
皆さんは知ってます ヘビに足がないんです
だから なかなか入っても見えません
そこで猫にはプラス価値を入れまして
ミルクをあげて大事に執着して育てますね
それで猫ちゃんが毛が立ててなんか威嚇するのを見たら
なんでこれは？とかね
遊んでるんでしょうか？と見たところで
机の下見たらヘビがいるんですね
それは外から入った動物
2つです 二人ですけどね
マムシだと見たところで
すぐ価値を入れるんでしょ
その場合はかなりマイナス価値を入れるんですね
可愛いではなくて怖いという風に
では ヘビには執着がないんですかね？あります
マイナス執着だからね
このマイナス道によってヘビを追い出すために
殺すために必死で頑張っちゃうんです
だから動くんで とにかく
猫を見たらでも動くんです
動かしたのは価値観なんです
ヘビを家の中にもうろろ巻いてる
ヘビを見たところで動くんです
その動きも執着なんです
だから この価値がマイナスであろうか
プラスであろうが関係ないんです
価値を入れたら執着はどんな程度かとも決めているんです
だから我々はものを測る価値を入れる
それから執着するべき強度を決める
結構頑張ってますね みんな
なんか淡々と生きて生きてるような気がしますけどね
気楽に 誰も気楽に生きてるわけじゃない
これやってるんです 瞬間瞬間
その中でも究極の価値を自分自我につけたいんです
つけたいのですではなくて
決まり的につけているんです
世の中にはダイヤにも価値ありますし
油田にも価値ありますけど
まあそれより自分には価値あります
何よりも油田一つよりも自分には価値があります
例えばね あなたにはこの油田の株のもう 30%あげますよと
ちょっと計算できない金額ですけどね
しかし その代わりに 1週間で死んでくれと
その代わりに寿命は全部欲しいと言ったら
だいたい結構ですと言いますね
皆様ならまあそれでもいいんだよ
それから何て言いますか
遺言書で子供に親戚に全部株を渡しちゃえばいいやと
でもその条件はないんです
あなただけで誰にも渡すことはできない
言ったら誰も結構やと言うでしょう
でも 油田の株の 30%だったら
1 日も何億でしょう 収入は
それでも寿命の方が ありがたいんです
そういうわけで 我々はやっぱり自分には一番究極の高い価値を入れてます
が なんかこの世界一になるとどうもうまくいかないんですよ
誰かが挑戦するんです
日本人の世界一ではなくて
現実的にこの世界一になる場合あるでしょ
いろんなところで もう戦ってとか
今回は何でしたっけ？なでしこったんとかっていうね
女性のチームがね もう一応優勝しましたね
これ優勝したんであって
それが世界一かどうかよくわかりませんだけど
一応世界一と日本では言ってます
で で これっていうのはなんか怪しいもんで
あまりもたないんですね
これが またすぐ誰かと競争
誰かがチャレンジするんです
この世界一というタイトルというのは常に奪われるようなものなんです
だから世界一というタイトルをつけたあの瞬間からもう大変ですよ
例えばスポーツの世界です
でもね 世界タイトルを取った時からもう大変なんです
物事は簡単ではいけません
すぐ厳しくなります 他のその同じスポーツの人々はとにかく挑戦する
はい それで私たち一人一人が自分に世界一ではなくて
宇宙一でもなく もう究極の価値を入れているんです
ですから 必ず攻撃を受けるんです
他の生命を見るたびに挑戦者なんですね
どんな生命も自分の世界一宇宙一タイトルに挑戦しているんです
ですから もう測りっぱなしですよ
それで自我の値にも分類がありますか？というね
あります 仏教は何でも分類しますからね
人間の価値観 デジタルではありません
まあデジタルと言った途端
テレビやと思いますけどね
あの まあただまあ日本語でデジタルと言うんだから
まあそれはまあデジタルということで
数字って意味なんですね
あの 人間というのは自分に価値を入れますけど
それはこのデジタルバリューではないんです
あの数字で表現できません
で ます重い 等しい 軽いという三種類の値が出ます
用語では高慢 道等慢 卑下慢となりますね
仏教用語でパーリ語だったらアティマーナ
サディサマーナ ヒーナマーナ
で 正しい順番がパーリ語でアティマーナワーコージョーマン
サディサマーナワードートーマン
ヒーナマーナワーヒゲマン
思っていたより重い 等しい
軽いという結果になるので
この 3つの値は常に変動するんです
だから自分が例えばアティマーナ高慢をつけたとしましょう
はい 私の値は高慢とバーコードをつけましたけど
また測るんだから それ外して別なことをつけなくちゃ
また外して別なことをつけなくちゃいけないんです
だからもういつでもこの値は不安定になるんです
いくら変動しても 大雑把に言えばこの 3つの中で動いているんです
慢は 3つだけですか？と
実は一つです 慢は測ることですからね
見方によって種類ができます
セット 1自分は他人より優れている
2自分は他人と等しい
自分は他人より卑しい
これセット 1 セット 2 優れて優れている人と比較する
分度は変わっちゃいますね
優れている人と比較すると
1自分は より優れている
この優れている人より優れている
あるいは等しい あるいは卑しい
あの人 あの人って相当偉いなと
で 自分を比較してみれば
あ 私の方がもっと偉いんだとと思うことなんですね
相当偉いんだけど まあ別に私もできますよと
私も同じでしょうということは等しいんですね
私なんかはと言った場合はもう 3番目ですね
卑下慢ですね それでセット 3
等しい人と比較すると
1自分はより優れている
2自分は等しい で 自分がその人よりは卑しいと決めることですね
で セット 4 卑しい人と比較する
1自分はより優れている
2自分は等しい  3自分はやっぱり卑しい
卑しい人と比較したら
やっぱり私の方がもっとダメでしょうと
セット 1 は基本なので
それを抜けると９つの慢があるんです
私はわざとセット 4 つ作りましたけど
仏典ではセット 3つですね
あるのは ですから  3 かける 3 ですから ９
つの慢があるんです はい
こんなことを出典がありますか？という質問だったら
アビダンマピタカの 3番目のテキストはヴィパッパカラナというんですね
あれは分析をするテキストなんです
で  389 ページに9種類のマーナを紹介しています
じゃあ全部 このパーリ語って難しいんだから
文字だけでも で ちょっと見るだけでね
これがテキストにあるナウヴィダーマーナということでね
まあこれは番号を振ってます
セイアッサセイヨウハマスミティマーナセイアッササディソウハマスミティマーナセイアッサヒーノウハマスミティマーナっていうのは
この優れている人と比較する 3つですね
それからサディサッサセイジョウハマスミティマーナサディサッササディソウハマスミティマーナサディサッサヒーノウハマスミティマーナっていうのは等しい人と比較
するセットですね
それから卑しい人と比較するセットは最後にあります
はい それからこの９つの
本当にそんなに慢がありますか？とかね
という疑問はあります
本当に９つですかね とかね
具体的な例の場合はね
私は12にしましたけど
テキストでは ないしセット 1 本来にある普通の慢ですね
慢というのは誰にでもあります
だから と 高慢 何でしたっけ？同等慢
卑下慢という 3つ 誰にでもあります
それぐらいでいいんです
理解は セット二から四まで理解するために思っていたのにを加えてみてください
そうすると ああ やっぱり十二もあるんだぞと
まあ九つもあるんだぞと見えてくるんです
本当は九つじゃなくて十二なんだと思います
私は で あの人よりできると
優れていると 偉いと思っていたのに
実は劣っていると これは日常算事で起こるでしょ？思っていたのにと出てくるでしょ
頭の中で あの思っていたのにという場合は
九つのマンのどこかに入っています
あんたどのように思っていたんですかと
まあ私よりは出来が悪いと思っていたのにと言ったら
卑しい人とその漫画で比較しているんです
あ よくできると思っていたのにと思ったところで
自分より優れている人と比較する漫画なんですね
だから簡単です 漫画を発見するの
この思っていたのにというところを入れてみれば
あの人は自分より劣っていると普通思っているなら
ならばそれは高慢 その場合は九番目ですね
はい 残りは自分で頑張って宿題でやってください
はい 測ること いわゆる慢というのは断然的に悪いんですかと
マナっていうのは仏教ではもう悪いものとして扱ってますよ
それでも今までの説明から見るとね
これって毎日やっていることだから
別に やっぱり条件によります
理性に基づいて自分を向上させるために
自分と他人を比較して測ることは構わないんです
どんどん自分を育て上げて
良い立派な人間に仕立てたいんです
それだったらいろいろ比較しないとね
スポーツの場合も 結構誰かものすごい優秀な人をモデルにして
もうその人を真似て練習するとかね
ありますよ ですから私たちは理性使っているならば
あ このままでは自分はダメやと
そんな高い価値がつけられませんよと
だから自分を何といいますか
向上させなくちゃいけないんだと
もう育てなくちゃいけないんだと
その自分を育てるために測ってみるんです
それは構わないんです
自我の錯覚が肯定する測りは悪い
この自我を肯定するために
やることは悪いんです
女性の化粧おしゃれと同じで
あれは自我を肯定するためにやっているんです
自分を向上させるためじゃないんです
だから結構悪行為なんです
知ったことじゃないんです
私には関係ありません
ということは このどんな
どんな慢で慢でも悪いではないんです
理性と絡んで自分をよりベターな良い
より良い人間に育て上げる慢であるならば
まあしょうがないんです
測ることで悪感情が悪感情が起こるならば
自分の能力が劣るならば
それがすごい悪いんです
説明する必要ない 時々我々はあの人はこうだ
この人はこうだとかね
ずっと考えているでしょう
で 会社のあの人はね いつでもおしゃれでかっこよくて
まあだからみんなに可愛がられちゃって
なんだあいつは能力もないでしょうとかね
まあ仕事もろくにできないのに
全部かっこつけて それで全部パスにしようと思っているんだとかね
例えば女性上司だったらね
一人の女性はかなり美人で
だからそこで美人パスなんですね
会社で別に能力がなくても
失敗しても あまり美人でない人
あんたこれちょっとやってくださいと頼むんですね
すっごく腹が立つんで
その人の なんで私はこの女の仕事までしなくちゃいけないんですかと
それで課長があの人と一緒に喫茶店でコーヒー飲んだりとかね
今日はちょっとお客さんの商売でお客さんと会うことがありますから
君も一緒に来てくださいと
仕事もできないんだから
ただ横に座っているだけなんですね
そこでもう一人の女の人
全部必要な資料を作って
作って ファイルを作って
もうはい 課長とあげなくちゃいかないんですね
腹が立ちますね これが
この女は何も仕事をしていないのに
もういいおしゃれ服を着て
もう課長と車で出かけたんだと
いうことで そのように我々は日常生活の中でいろんな比較はしますよ
これ真似なんですね 慢ですね
その場合は自分が気持ち悪くて
気持ち悪くて 怒って 嫉妬が出てきて
恐ろしくなってくるんですね
ものすごい病気になってしまうんですね
それがもう断言的に悪なんですね
例えば 自分よりこの人は仕事は上手ですし
ただあんた下手でしょって言ったら
ちょっとプライド傷つくでしょ
その人が じゃあちょっと 1週間ぐらいあんた見てみなさいと
そのうちじゃあ待ってみろよと
これも慢なんです はい
待ってみろよと言って
この 1週間  2週間でむちゃくちゃ仕事を学んで腕を上げてどうですかと
言うと 自分がもう上がっているんですね
その場合は精神的にあんまり壊れることはないんです
だから言われまったとかね
傷ついたとかね どうせ 1年先に会社に入ったんだから
もう仕事をわかっているのは当たり前でしょうね
なのになんで新入社員の私をね
そんな風に言うのかい？とかね
そういう風に比較してみると
もうダメになっちゃうんですね
解脱を目指す人には障害になる束縛です
十の産業寺の9番目です
だから測ること 慢が悪いですか？ということに
こういう風に答えなくちゃいけないんです
条件によって悪い場合も悪くない場合でもありますよと
慢が悪いんです はい 悪いですよとは答えになりません
そんな簡単で 慢が悪くないでしょうという
そんなことは簡単なことじゃないんです
これを覚えておいてください
条件によって自分を向上する方向へ慢が働いてくるならば
まあ構わない 自分を精神的に病気になって壊れてしまう慢だったら
もうこれはもう危険で
もし解脱を目指すならば
慢そのものが悪いんです
どんなタイプの慢であっても
だから慢には白い慢と黒い慢があると言ったでしょ
結局は 自分を育てるマンは白いもので
自分を破壊するマンは黒いもので
しかし 解脱を目指しているならば
白い黒い関係ないんです
悪いと 全部マンは捨てなくちゃいけない
それで我々は輪廻に結んでいる束縛は十
十あります その中で九番目
あれは切る順番で教えているんです
九番目っていうのは相当切りにくいという意味なんです
マンが起こる順番がありますかと
順番はありません その時の感情
妄想 体調 環境などによって
九種類のマンの中で一つが起こります
順番がないんです 例えば高慢の次
道道等マンだよとかね
道等マンの次は卑下 そんなことはないんです
この環境によります 誰に会ったのかいっていうことなんです
それだけじゃなくて 環境も同じなんですよ
環境によっても もうもう高慢になったり
卑下マンになったりもします
例えば落ち込んでいる時
卑下マンとかね なんか能力あるんだけど
ちょっと結構落ち込んでいるんですね
仕事もできるんだけど
今はすごい落ち込み中
その時は俺なんかそんな仕事できるわけないんだとかね
どうしたっても失敗するだろうとかね
いうふうな気分はもう卑下マンになっているんです
気分爽快の時 高慢のグループとかね
気分爽快の時は仕事の能力ないんだけど
まあやってあげますから
どうぞどうぞというふうに態度をとっちゃいますね
だからどんなマンが現れるかということはなかなか大変ですよ
その時 その時の条件で決めてしまいます
心には慣れる癖があるので
起こるマンのパターンができて正確になることはあります
これ気をつけてください
心っていうのは いつでもこの
癖というかね それは心の特色でどうしようもないんです
我々勉強するということは癖をつけるんです
何か外国語を学ぶということは
繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し練習して
その癖を形状記録 なんだらかんだでなんとか言葉がありますね
それ使い簡単だけど なかなか単語を思い出せなくて忘れ
忘れちゃったんだ もうやめたんです
今なんかこの服とかシャツとかありますね
形状を記録しているっていう
だから普通 もういろいろ形潰れても
ちゃんともう自動的に元の形になるというね
そのような 脳が学ぶということは
いろんな形状を状態を記録しておくんです
だから癖つくことですよ
これが我々の勉強であり
学ぶことなんです だから何か繰り返しちゃうと
いとも簡単にできるようになります
それで繰り返して 何回何回の高慢だったらやばい
かなり高慢性格になるんです
これでみんなにバレちゃいます
この性格はこの値が もうあの
何といいますか あの油性ペンで書いちゃうと
マジックインクで書くとすごくやばいんです
あのシールで貼った方がいいんです
すぐ外れますからね これでこの例えば何回
何回 何回も高慢になったりするとかね
で 私はあの この 自分の国のね
学校で教えてる先生という連中が知ってますけど
あの連中には あの なんて言いますか
仕事をしている間ね 退職するまではね
何教えたっても理解しないんです
だから世界一アホでバカなんです
私はもうたまたま知ってる人が来て喋っても
一切にもしたくない あんたどこの高校の先生？どうですか？はい
さようならと あの大学の教員とは違います
なぜか相当な高慢なんです
だって毎日何も知らない子供たち相手でしょうに
毎日 毎日だから冗談じゃないんですよ
もう家族よりも長い間
こういう人々は 子供たち相手にしているのです
これで高慢ももう相当高慢な
だからそこでなってしまって
退職したらガクンと落ちるんです
何にもできなくて もう社会で社会に入ってみたら
何もできない これでやっとまあ私たちにも喋られるようになります
それで逆に何でもよくこうですか
そうですか そうですかとよく聞くようになります
だから学校の教師たちは
私は退職するまで待ってるんです
退職したら こいつらはなんとか人の話を聞くだろうと
この人の話を聞かないということは
もう度を越した とんでもない向上漫なんですね
度を越しちゃうと もうもう治らないんです
そういう人々は処分しなくちゃいけないんです
もう かなり大変です はい
そこで皆様に教えたいというのは
我々ももうたまたまなんかそっちゅう高慢になったり
ちょっとそっちゅう卑下慢になったりする場合あるならば
とことん気をつけてください
もうそっちゅう卑下慢になっちゃうと
これがもう慣れてしまうんですね
心に 慣れちゃったらもう性格なんです
だから私は前説明したでしょ
自分の値っていうのはすーっと変化するもんなんです
今高慢になったのに もう 1 秒以内でまた卑下慢になったりとかね
もうぐるぐる変わるんですよ
だからそれは普通で しかし
高慢になる回数が大きくなると慣れてしまっちゃいます
それでもうマジックインクで書いてしまいますね
値を だからそれで困ります
で 自分がマジックインクで自分の高慢の値変えても
中身は変わってすっと変化しているんです
落ち込んだりいろいろありますよ
しかし 社会があいつは高慢やと決めてしまったら
もう自分が落ち込んでいる時では助けてくれないんです
あの高慢野郎はね 放っておけと
という感じになるんです
だから慢はできる あるのはあるんだけど
性格にならないようにした方がいいんです
はい 慢の癖があるなしの違いは何ですか？と
悲観主義者 被害妄想 傲慢な人
頑固者などの表現でもわかるように
慢の癖ができたら発見しやすい
すぐバレます だから癖があるなしってすごい違いますよ
私は言うでしょ？あの人は何でしたっけ？悲観主義者よと
この悲観主義者というのは
いつでも喋ったら何か否定的で
で このダイヤですよ これすごくいいもの
でももうじゃあカラットでしょうにと言うんです
あのね  1キロのダイヤがないんだって言いたくなりますけど
だから悲観主義者はそういうふうに言うんですね
だから それで性格はバレるし
性格バレたらこの慢の性格バレると
大体みんなその人々を捨てるんです
仲間に入れてくれないんです
例えば頑固者やと人に言う場合は
相手にしたくないという意味なんですよ
だからこれが大変なところで
このコミュニケーションを切断されるんです
だから できるだけバレないようにするしかないんです
慢は他人にバレないようにしなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 精神病に陥りやすいし
しかしではないんです
直しがたいんです このように
あの またこの病気になり
私は神様や私は釈尊のブッダの生まれ変わりだっていうのは
もうもう終わり そういう人々は
福島原発を確保するときは
そこに放り込んだ方がいいんです
全く出てこられないようにと
死んでから灰も宇宙船に乗って宇宙にどこかに捨てた方がいいんです
それぐらいもう危険なんです
それぐらいコミュニケーションを取った方がいいんです
それは高慢がもう度を越している場合はね
一般の方々の場合は この卑下慢なんですね
かなり問題を起こすのは
私はまあ大したことはないやとかね
そこで何回毎日毎日繰り返しちゃうと
もう何の役にも立たない人間になってしまいますね
だからみんなコミュニケーションを切ってしまいますよ
コミュニケーションを切るということは大変なことで
親にも構ってくれなくなっちゃうし
親も早く出て行ってくれと言うし
仕事はないし もうないんです
誰も受け入れません 大変なんです
で 癖になってない場合は
慢はその都度わかります
例えば漫画癖になってない場合は
自分でわかります あっ
俺が自画自賛してるんだと
今落ち込んでいるんだと
その時わかります これも治るわけはないが
気をつければ良いんです
だから 漫画は癖になったらもうさようならなんです
それすごい気をつけてほしいんです
しかし みんなに漫画あります
それはまあ 癖にならないようにしてほしいんです
まあ悪い言葉で言えば
優柔不断でいいんだよと
まあ時々高慢になったり
また落ち込んだり また舞い上がったりという感じのね
そっち変わる漫画はまあそれほど危険じゃないんです
コミュニケーション切れないんですね
みんな嫌 嫌なやつやと言わないんです
例えば えらい気分が悪くなって傲慢がってる時は
みんなそのうちニコニコと笑ってきますからね
ちょっとそっておきましょうと待ってるんですね
気持ち変わるまでは だから捨てて捨てられてないんです
漫画とは自分のアイデンティティでしょう
今日の僕は一応質問に答える形式にしたんです
簡単にしたかったんです
だからまあ誰も私にまとめの質問する人一人もいないんだからね
私は自分で質問を作る
自作自演なんです 本当に誰かが質問するならば
もっと中身のある話できます
で こういうことを考えて
漫画っていうのは自分の存在値でしょ
自分の価値はなんぼかいっていうことでしょ
だから自分のアイデンティティなんですね
皆に生きてる限り 自意識
自分がいるという実感があります
アイデンティティとは
自分の自分と  自分と他人を
自分と他人を区別することです
ちょっと直してください
これ今 アイデンティティというのは
自分と他人を区別することですよ
そんな大したことじゃないんです
アイデンティティは漫画なんです
当然 生命は個なので セルフアウェアネスというものはあります
あの生命っていうのは集合体じゃないんです
サンゴ礁も集合体じゃないんです
あれ 体が繋がってるだけで
一個一個別な生命なんです
ですから この一個一個の生命に自分がいるんだという実感があります
それはセルフアウェアネスと言うんですね
自分がいるということは知ってますね
これに価値をつけることで
曲者の漫画に変わってしまうんです
なんか微妙なことを言ってますよ
自分がいるんでしょうっていうことは別にしょうがないんです
私はこちらにいて 皆さんはそちらにいると
生きてるんだという実感
いつでもあるでしょう
これ生きてるんだからしょうがないでしょ
しかし この生きてるんだっていうことに
これはなんぼですかと聞くでしょ？私は
私の価値はなんぼですか？と
そこが曲者の漫画になるんです
そこでちょっと問題が起こるんです
自分の価値を探すことで
だから誰も自由になってないんです
誰にでもセルフアウェアネスというものはありますね
だから自分がいるでしょうに
実感あるでしょう これがある限り
私はどんな程度の存在かとも好きに知りたくなるんです
これから漫画が割り込むんです
価値観がないと凡夫は生きていられません
だからこれ じゃあ私は生きてるんだけど
何者でもありませんと
というふうな気分で生きていられないんです
1 秒も生きていられないんです
どうしても生きるために何か価値が必要なんです
自分の人生調べてください
椅子から立つためにも何か価値観が必要なんです
でないと椅子座った椅子から立てません
例えばコーヒーを飲みたくなりました
自分の家に瓶に入っているインスタントコーヒーもあるし
それからあの なんて言いますか
パッケージに開けて入れるなんとかコーヒーもあるし
それからコーヒーメーカーもあるし
コーヒー豆もあるし じゃあどちら飲む？はい
すぐ決めてください 決められないでしょ
その瞬間で価値を入れるんです
だから客観的に見れば
豆を潰してコーヒーメーカーで作るコーヒーがもう品質いいに決まっている
次にあの紙パッケージを開けてお湯を注いで
あれも普通のコーヒーの粉ですからね
2番目それなんです インスタントは 3番目なんです
あれは人工的に作っているんだから
では 皆様はいつだってコーヒーメーカーでコーヒー飲みますかというと
そうじゃないんです だからその瞬間でどちらにするのかいと
というところでも価値を入れなくちゃいけないんです
例えば友達に あのコーヒー
コーヒー飲む？紅茶飲む？日本茶にする？と友達に聞く
友達は返事しなくちゃいけないんでしょ
価値を入れなくちゃいけないんです
だから価値を入れずに生きていられないんです
だから私たちの仏教の問題ところは
これが悪いと言っているんだから
例えば椅子に座る 座っていて価値入れます
座った座っているよりは
このこういうことで散歩をした方がいいと
価値が入ったでしょ それで椅子から立って歩くことにするんです
こちらうろうろ歩くよりは座っていた方が町やと思ったら座ってるんです
だからどんな行動も価値が決めてくれるんです
価値がつけるのは自分が生きているんだからなんです
生きていることはどうしようもないんですが
この価値をつけることはかなり曲者になっちゃうんです
だからといって あなた方には価値なし生きられますかと聞いたら
これは無理です 絶対無理
価値観なくなくなっちゃうと
あの 何といいますか 吉野家さんでご飯食べることもできなくなるんです
だっていくつか同じものなんですけどね
吉野家さんでしたっけ？なんかの肉を肉の破片を
あれ 何て言いますか 日本語
え？牛丼 あ 牛丼ですね
あれ 外国で売ってる破片がありますね
ステーキ あれやこれやと使えないものはね
これ大量に出来上がるんで
それを安く輸入して あれを煮出して煮出して煮出して
もうもう油ばっかりばっかりなんですけど
牛丼屋さんでまあ安く売ってます
200円程度というかね
24時間もやってます
しかし 価値観がなければ
そんなところでもご飯食べられないんです
理由はいくつかのメニューがあるんで
中身は同じですけど それでもいくつかのメニューがあるんです
生卵を入れるか入れないかとかね
ご飯別で なんとか肉は別にもってくるか
ご飯の上にのせて丼にのせてもらうかどうかね
いろいろそれによって値段も変わります
だから一つ選べないとね
だから私たちの人生はもう秒単位で価値観で管理されているんです
うん それでびっくり 漫画は本の不可欠という意味ですかと
だから次にこの疑問が出てくるでしょ
もう価値観で生きてるんだから
漫画で生きてるんだから
え？これ本能ですかと
輪廻転生する生命には漫画
漫画 本能で不可欠です
たとえ悟っても 阿羅漢果になるまで消えないのもそのわけです
阿羅漢果になったら もうそれから輪廻転生しないんです
そこまでそれ必要なんです
完全に悟りに達するまで
生命には慢の鎖を外すことはできません
だからもう鎖もつけてます
ずっと判断しなくちゃいけないんです
自分の価値はなんぼかいと
これでくたくた精神的にやられます
全く落ち着かなくなっちゃいます
いてもたってもいられなくなります
初めからも不安があったのに
どんどん不安が限りなく回転していくんです
だからといってどうしようもないんです
これが輪廻というんです
いつでも悪循環 悪循環
悪循環でこの人生が成り立っています
今の場合 私は悪循環のことを教えましたし
だから皆様 この輪廻輪廻とか
日本語日本でよく聞いていますけど
あんな単純シンプルなことじゃなくて
各項目どちら見ても悪循環が出ているはずなんです
私は今まで長い年月喋ってきましたけど
ずっとこの悪循環を示しているはずなんです
いろんなところで 因果法則であろうか
苦しみの説明であろうか
欲の説明であろうか 今日の満の説明であろうか
物の見事にそこに悪循環というのは
矛盾というのも同じことなんですね
入り込んでいるんです
終わらない 切りがないという
だから慢の場合も同じことで
切りがなく回転するんです
しかし 慢は様々なトラブルを起こす原因にもなるのです
煩悩です だから煩悩なら煩悩らしく迷惑かけるなよと
あなた本能でしょうにと
あなたなしに生きていられないでしょう
だからおとなしくしなさいと
それはないんですね 例えば
我々人間がもう遺伝子構造によって生命は成り立っているでしょ
結局がんになる遺伝子もガンにするのも遺伝子なんです
老いることも遺伝子の仕業なんです
いい加減にしろよと言いたいんだけど
やってくれないんですね
遺伝子は我々の話は聞きません
遺伝子の勝手で我々はもう髪の毛がなくなるわ
歯が先に折れるわ もういろいろ糖尿病になるわ
もう早くも老けてしまうわとかね
あるいは脳細胞が壊れてもう認知症になってるんだけど
なかなか死なないわとかね
そんなもう何も自分ではできないんですね
遺伝子は全部勝手にやるんです
これはもう物質なことだからわかりやすいでしょ
心もまた別で 心にもそうやって遺伝子みたいないろいろ要因があります
これはなしに心は成り立たない
この要因もまた曲者なんです
だから勝ちつけるのは心なんです
だからマナは足のお腹の問題じゃないんです
足にはマナがないんです
手にもマナがないんです
マナがあるのは心の中なんです
肉体は肉体を比較しません
で マナがあるのはいいんだけど
なくては生きていられないんだけど
そのマナ自身が我々をまた破壊するんですね
はい 次 マナのこの悪さを勉強してみましょう
ちょっと休憩した方がいいみたいね
それでは 10 分間休憩いたしますので
8時半にまたお戻りください
はい では では始まります
はい これからあの慢というのは
もう今までの説明っていうのは
これは本能であってね
まあ生きる上では欠かせないものなんですね
しかし これがかなり厄介なもので
これって人生みんなそうでしょうね
ご飯食べなきゃ糖尿病にもならないしね
太らないしね 放射あの
何でしたっけ？何被曝って言うんですか？まあ体内被曝もしないしね
でもだからといって食べないでいるわけにもいきませんし
そんな何でもそんな風になってますね
わがまま 自我を張ること
頑固は悪いとは常識になってます
仏教でなくてもね みんな言いますね
わがままは悪いんだよと
自我を張るなよというのは
これは誰でも言ってますからね
だから漫画悪いってみんな知ってるんです
常識だから悪いではありません
しかし みんな知ってるんだから悪いわけじゃないんです
人は 誰でもエゴ わがまま
自我張ることの悪果を経験しているんです
みんな言ってるんだから悪いんじゃなくて
我々長い歴史の中でわがままで自我でどれほど困ってきたのかという経験があるんですね
自我あるいは慢が悪性になると
客観性がなくなって自分のことしか見えなくなるんです
だから自我イコール慢なんですね
これからで 自我であろうか
慢であろうか ちょっと悪性になるんですね
体の細胞は悪性になったらもう終わりでしょう
ガンですからね これだから自我っていう気持ちも
慢というね 測る癖も悪性になっちゃうんです
悪性になった途端 もう理性がひとかけらもなくなっちゃって
自分のことばっかり考えるんです
これで何をやっても悪い結果になるんです
慢が悪性になったら もう何やっても結果悪い
理性がなくなっているんですね
だから大変です 慢が消せません
しかし 要注意しておかないと
これがちょっとしたことで悪性になってしまいます
多岐に分かれる慢の元は何ですか？と
で 慢はいろんな 今日は皆様に 19つの種類を教えましたけど
さらに経典を調べたところで
またいろんなカテゴリーがあるんです
で そのカテゴリーも調べてみましたけど
まあまあいいやとカットしたんです
まあちょっともうややこしいんです
だからまあ大体簡単に覚えてください
まあ高慢 常とう慢 卑下慢という 3 種類でも分かれるでしょうね
この元は何ですか？と
大本は無明です 無明というね
ことがあるんですね 無明というのはよくわからないということなんです
当たり前のことだからね
我々はすべてわかって生まれたわけじゃないでしょうね
振り返ってみたら生まれているんでしょ
死ぬまでも同じことでね
よくわからないんですね
ます 人に自我意識があります
認識の結果から起こる錯覚ですね
それがあの自我意識っていうのは
もう錯覚とはずっと言ってますよ
これは認識すると起こるんです
何か何か見えたら あ 俺がいるんだという錯覚が起こるんです
音を聞いていると あ 私がいるんだという余計な錯覚が生まれるんです
生命は自分自身のことを何よりも好むので
自分に価値をつけます
自分の命に普通究極の価値をつけるので
自我意識は慢に化けるし
だから見えたり聞こえたりすると自我意識が生まれます
これ錯覚です 自分がいるということ
それ 錯覚がすぐに もう自分には究極の価値を入れているんだからね
慢に化けてしまいますね
これが高慢なのです ですから元は高慢です
あの 12に分かれても
誰でも基本的に高慢の種があるんです
この高慢の種が育てると
あれやこれやと種類が出てくるんです
高慢があるんだから卑下慢にもなります
だからもともと生命は高慢だよということは理論的じゃないんです
だからマーナという言葉を使うんです
マーナのレベル高いところは高慢というんですね
だからもともとのマーナがよく見るとそれが高慢なんです
価値観で見ると 一番高い価値は自分の命に入れます
では漫画はなんで二手に分かれるんでしょうかと
生きてみると 自我中心的な高慢が現実と合わないことに気づきます
子供たちによくありますよ
家でお母さんに世界一世界一だと育てて
幼稚園に行った途端気づくんですね
あ 俺が世界一ではなかったと
だから誰でも内心は世界一なんです
大体頭が病気の場合は
それはずっとバラすんです
だから日本のマスコミなんか聞いてみると
いつでも世界一の歌ばっかりなんです
何かほんのちっぽけなことでも
あー世界一や世界一やとかね
何でもいいんです なんて言いますかね
スイカの種飛ばすとか
そしてこれでも世界一を目指すんですね
勝手にしろよと だからアメリカのやり方がいいでしょうに
アメリカはやることは全部世界一
別に誰もそれに挑戦しません
比較もしません だから簡単です
で アメリカはベースボールやってるでしょ
アメリカだけですよ 誰もアメリカとベースボールやらないんです
そこでこれ ワールドカップというんですね
勝手にしなさいと ワールドカップだったら
世界の各国と競争しなくちゃあかんでしょ
でないんです アメリカの中のいくつかの地方にある
もうくだらんいろいろ野球
まあ野球も同じこと ベースボールも同じこと
何人かなんですよ 野球の場合でも
アメリカの野球で一になった
あれは世界一なんですね
例えば日本で一になっても世界一とは言わないんですね
おかしい これから世界一って言ってください
今も野球始めたんだからね
そこでまあ試合で最後に優勝を決めるでしょ
アメリカで各所で優勝を決めたら
優勝チームが世界 ワールドリーグベースボールなんで
なんだこりゃと 皆さんは一度もそれなんだこれ？と思ったことないでしょ？まあマインドコントロールは洗脳されてますからね
だからそこまで病気なら勝手にいればいいでしょうに
私は世界一やと 結局は我々一人一人も内心ね
自分の存在は世界一だと思っているんです
これはかっこ悪くてバラすもんでしょうかね
これバラす場合は何でも世界一は俺たちは世界一やと
もう治らないんです もう
精神的にもイカれている
その場合は だからそこら辺ちょっと気をつけた方がいいんです
で あの 私たちはそれでもともと世界一やと思って生まれたんです
生まれた時からそんなこと思ってなかったんですけど
生まれたら実感が生まれるんでしょ
生まれてからこの実感で
もう自分が偉くなっちゃうんですね
それで赤ちゃんの間はいいんだけど
どんどん大きくなってくると
なんかちょっと現実に合わないんですね
その時慢を捨てれば良いのに
無明なので失敗します
だから幼稚園に行ったら
他の子供たちはギャーギャー言ったり
蹴ったり踏んだりするとね
私は世界一でしたのにね
違うみたいんだと まあいいや
そんなアホなことをこりっきり考えませんよと
思っちゃえばいいのに
やっぱり子供にそんなことわからないでしょ
慢はよくないんだと 自我はよくない
わからないでしょう 無明ですから
やっぱり慢を作って それから苦しむ羽目になります
現実に合わせて高慢を高慢
道統慢 卑下慢に変えるんです
だから自分が高慢なんです
で 高慢は現実に合わせてたら
じゃあやっぱり卑下慢にしようかなと
しょうがないと じゃあ道統慢にしよう
しょうがない この場合はということで
もう価値を変えるんです
もとは我がこそ我こそ偉いと思う根拠のない愚かさなんです
なんで慢に慢がなるのかというと
我こそ偉いという根拠のない錯覚なんです
あります それは 慢に強弱はありますか？という質問
当然ありますね で 慢が薄い人も厚い人もいます
また 日常薄くなったり厚くなったりもします
基本的に慢が厚い人もいるし
薄い人もいるし またそれに関わらず厚くなったり薄くなったりという場合もあります
慢は 一 繊細的になる いわゆる機能しないんだけど
繊細状態にあります 皆様にはないんです
で これが瞑想して煩悩を抑えて
煩悩なくて悟りに達する場合なんです
阿羅漢果になってない方々の場合は
だいたい慢は寝るんです
俺が寝るぞと 二 普通に現れる
だから気づかないんですね
大体気づかない まあ普通に皆様に毎日日常 24時間もある自分自我意識が普通の慢なんです
これ慢やと思わないでしょ
思わない 三 強くなるんですね
気づく可能性があるんです
普通と違って何か落ち込んだり
普通と違って舞い上がったりする時もありますね
その時は あ 俺が何か自我張ってるんじゃない？とか感じる可能性はあります
なんか今はちょっとすごい落ち込んでるんじゃない？とかね
気づいてほしい その場合は落ち込んでるとは今落ち込み中やとハッキリしてほしい
舞い上がっているときは
今舞い上がって興奮中であると
そういう風にハッキリすると慢がかなり管理できます
四 異常になる 他人に分かります
慢がちょっと異常になると
本人にわからない 他人に分かります
そのセクションですよ
我々使っているのは 皆様もよく日常言っているのは
あの人は傲慢だとかね
あの人は態度でかいんだとかね
言ってるところ 普通社会でこの異常になっている時なんです
普通も態度でかいんだけど
気づかないんです 人にバレるところまで態度でかくなると
それは異常ということなんです
ということは前も言いましたからね
皆様の慢度が読めたらダメです
他人に 皆様の慢の値が他人に読めたらもう異常です
だから慢があるんだけど
他人に読めない程度にしておかないと
だから普通世界はいい人だよと
謙虚な方で 仕事を頼んだら真面目に頑張ってくれるし
というふうに言う場合は
もう慢は読めてないんです
本人がそれなりに管理しているんです
ああ あの人は仕事はできるんだけど
ちょっとわがままで態度はでかいんだと言っちゃうと
もうバレてますね その場合はもう異常です
慢は だからこれから皆様はもう慢が消え去りませんだからこの慢は他人にバレないような程度にした方がいいんですね
他人にバレるともう足はもう取られています
業もあります 度を越す
その時は罪を犯すんですね
その時気づかないんです
本人がもう狂ってるんです
もう 気づくわけないんです
だからプライドを傷ついたと思ったら人を殺すでしょ
だから特にあの いろんな場合は
人のプライドを傷つけるとかなり危ないんですよ
だから人を侮辱することやらね
プライドを傷つけるような言葉を言うことやら
ものすごい危険なんです
そこで慢がもう度を越してしまいます
だから私たちも人の慢も異常にならないようにと
そうとしないと 相手の慢が異常になると
それだけでも粗相なんですよ
もうちょっと失敗したら
これ度を越えちゃうと何になるかわからないんです
はい それが強弱の問題です
慢の 次 慢は人生に与える影響は何ですか？と
慢は無知無明の子で仲良しのペアです
慢の母親は無明です まあだから親子は仲良しでしょう
この二人がいつでも一緒に行動するんです
欲と慢という心情の心情は同時に生まれるんです
それで心で慢が生まれると
欲もあるんです 欲 欲がなく
慢が生まれません 当然親子はペアだからね
無明は当然あります だから慢というのは親子で
無明と慢は親子で 欲は
まあこの子供が隣の子供とえらい仲良し友達という感じなんです
どこへ行っても この友達は手をつないでつないで一緒にいると
しかし 自分がいるところにいつでも母親がついてくるんですから
三人組なんです まず欲と絡んで自我中心的な人間になります
この欲と慢が絡むんだから
人間はほとんど自我中心
自分のことばっかり考えるんです
だから私は断言的に言うでしょう
世の中で慈しみはないんだよと
この他宗教で愛とかあんだらかんだら言ってますけど
あんなのは何のこともないんだよと
人類に初めて愛というか慈しみを教えてのはお釈迦様だよと
どんな宗教でも愛は良いことだと言ってないんです
あんなのは愛でも愛着であって慈しみじゃないんです
それはありえないんです
ここまで精密に心は勉強した人はいますかね
心理学でもこういう風に勉強する
やってないでしょ だから仏教は精密に心をバラしてバラして語ってるんです
だから精密に本能的な命を見てみると
欲と慢が一緒に行動してますね
欲と慢が合わせると自我中心であって
愛着であって 自分のことを考えるんです
自分に利益があるならば
あるならば 人のことも愛してみるんです
だから隣人を愛しなさいと神が言ったんだから
あいつはもうやくざのドンだから
あいつの言葉を聞くと
自分にも何かご褒美をくれるだろうと
最後の審判で天国に招かれるだろうという企みがあって
隣人を愛するんです しかし
隣人ではなくて 隣の国は爆弾を落とすんです
それが慈しみですかね
こんな腹黒い気持ちで人を愛したっても善行になりませんよ
で これは私は他宗教に対して怒って言ってるわけじゃなくて
心理学的に言うんです
ありえないんだよと ですから
この心の中で信条として
慢と欲がペアで一緒なんです
で 欲には慢がなくても生まれますが
慢が生まれる場合は必ず欲が仲良しでこなくちゃいけないんです
次 慢は無知を強化します
だから親子で外へ出て
あれやこれやと頑張って子供が頑張ると
親の鼻が高いでしょう
大したことはやってないんですけど
子供は はちょっと空手のゲームででも自分の子供が勝ったら
まあ親の鼻が高いこと
だからどうにもならん
この慢という子がいることで威張ってすごくたちがもう鼻が高いのは無明なんです
だから慢が働けば働くほど無明が強化するんです
だから誰も気づかないんです
このシステムは まあわかりやすく言えばどんどんバカになるんです
慢を動かせば動かすほど
どんどんバカになるんです
これはわかりやすい言葉
でもそれも専門的な表現じゃないんです
まあ威張ってみてくださいと
とことんバカになりますよということなんです
威張れば威張るほどアホなんです
目が腫れれば腫れるほど
もう笑っちゃうほどアホにバカになるんです
だからそういう具体的なケースででも覚えておいてください
例えば見え張る人がいるでしょ
見栄を張る場合は結構アホなことやらなくちゃあかんでしょ
もうお腹が空いてるのにご飯食べないで見栄張ってる
金もないのに高い服を買ったり
また見栄張る 自分の子供が大した能力ないのに
なんとしてでもちょっと世の世界で
もうアホな連中が子供入れる学校とかいるでしょ
タレントさんが有名人の子供とか入れるね
そういうアホな学校にどうしても入れたくて無理をするんですね
無理をして入れたのはいいんだけど
それからあの脳細胞ないおばあさんたちというか
奥さんたちと一緒に毎日生活しなきゃいかんでしょ
みんな金持ちで その連中と一緒に見栄張ると
もう死んだ方がマシじゃないのかと思いますけど
だから借金してでも 何としてでもそうやって見栄張ることになると
もう信じられないアホなことするんです
だから無明は強化するという意味なんです
無知とはすべての悪 心情
とですねと同時に必ず生まれるんです
この無明サンガ すべての悪
の心の中に生まれるんです
無知は 慢はそうじゃないんです
慢は生まれたり 生まれなかったり
慢は欲の心でしか生まれません
欲という仲良し友達がないと
慢がもうあまり臆病で出てこないんです
だから今までの説明で慢というのはすごい態度でしょ
また見るとまたすごい複雑なんです
態度でかいんだけど 相当臆病者で欲がないと出てこないんです
その代わりに慢はこのお母さんをどんどんどんどんもう強化してあげるんです
お母さんは無知という人なんです
無知っていうのは すべての悪を管理するんです
一切の悪の総合監督というか
偉い監督なんです それでいい監督があればどうなります？結構結果出しますでしょ
だから監督が強ければ強いほど
悪が重い分 結果出すんです
無知が強ければ 悪心情は力を発揮します
ただ 皆様方 怒っても人は怒鳴りたいんですね
怒鳴りたくないんです
そこで無明という監督がいるんですね
監督が結構強いだったらどうなるんです
もっと強くなったらぶん殴るんです
相手を もっと無明の監督はしっかりしているならば
怒ったら相手を殺すんです
だから悪信女がどれぐらい結果実績出すかっていうことは
無明という監督が決めるんです
だから皆様にも欲があるでしょうに
だからといって盗まないでしょ
人のものは もっと金が欲しいでしょうに
だからで人の財布は取らないでしょう
だから皆様の無明の監督は腰がちょっとやばいんですね
心の強い無明の監督がついちゃうと
金がなかったら誰の金でも盗る
そういうことで この無明という監督を強化するのは誰ですかというと
慢なんです ちょっとこれすごい難しいポイントですよ
考えてください 慢は表に出て仕事しないんです
慢は無明を強化するんです
たまたま表に出たくなる場合は
欲と一緒に出るんです
そこで慢がずっと無明を強化するんです
無明が悪の監督です 無明が強くなればなるほど
悪は力が発揮するんです
だから大変です だから複雑な関係です
慢が人にどんな影響を与えるのかというと
そんな風に影響を与えるんです
例えば人が喧嘩したとしましょう
慢は当然絡んでますよ
なんであんた私にそんなこと言うの？か言って喧嘩するでしょ
慢でしょ しかし 慢は喧嘩しないんです
プライド傷ついたんだからといって喧嘩しません
プライド傷ついたところで無知が強くなるんです
そこで無知が怒りを監督するんです
怒りと慢は一緒に生まれないんです
そこで無知がもう強くなったところで
怒りにぶん殴れと言うんです
そこでぶん殴るんです
しかし 私たちはあまり頭が良くないんだから
やっぱりあんた高慢のせいで罪を犯しましたと言うんです
あれ 高慢のせいでもないんです
まあ高慢は当然絡んでいますけど
裏で待ってるんです それだけ
プライド傷ついたら 慢
怒るのは腹が立つのは無知なんです
だって子供なんか怒鳴ったら
なんで勉強しなかった？って言ったら
お母さんがかなり先生に当たるんだから
なんでうちの子にそんなこと言うのかい？と
そういうことでしょ？日本の場合は
子供育てられませんでしょ
だって母がついているんだから
そういうことで子供を叱っても
別にそれ子供の問題ですけど
どこかで見る母が怒って訴えて裁判までかけたりとか
子供はそんなことやりませんよ
しかし その代わりに子供は自分の母を強化したんだ
動かしてないんです お母さん
先生に対して訴えてくださいって言わないんです
ただ落ち込むだけで 先生にこんなこと言われちゃった
明日学校に行きたくないんだと言うだけ
それからお母さんがああそうかいと言って
えらい喧嘩をして 警察に訴えるところまでやっちゃいます
だからそのシステムですよ
慢と慢がお母さんという無知を強化する
無知のお母さんが怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 欲などなどの煩悩を監督する
監督して酷いことをさせるんです
慢は直接何もしない 無知を強化するから
欲 怒り 嫉妬などの心女が影響を与えて結果を出します
慚愧の行為を起こします
だから行動するのは無知が強くなった時なんです
慢ではないんです とても危険なので
理性を失うことです だから慢
無明が強くなったということは
理性がないということなんです
だから気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
感情の奴隷になってしまいます
これも慢がやっているわけじゃないんです
慢が無知をいじるんです
そうするとお母さんがもう他の煩悩をいじって
もう感情の奴隷にしてしまいます
だから感情の奴隷ということは
見事に無知に監督されているんだということなんです
だから失敗 すべての失敗は無知で起こるんです
それは慢が絡んでいるんです
これは親と子の関係で覚えておいてください
いつでもその子はお母さんと一緒にいるんです
だから子供を蹴ったら腹が立つのはお母さんです
訴えるのはお母さんなんです
子供は蹴られたあと泣くだけで
あるいはもう蹴ったら
まあ友達だからニコッと笑っているかもしれません
全然気にしないで それでもお母さんが腹が立つんです
もう一つあります イミューンシステムというものがありますね
体に免疫機能が壊れてしまったらどうなりますか
それだけでは何の問題もありません
皆様の体に免疫機能があります
それは完全機能しなくなったとしましょう
どうってことないんです
全然心配する必要はないんです
それで しかし 外の空気を吸っただけでも
細菌に感染されて死ぬかもしれません
免疫機能が壊れたんだから人は死にません
空気吸っても十分です
この空気の細菌が肺に入って
はい 終わり さようなら
どんな細菌にもその体を壊すことができます
だから世の中でたくさん細菌あるでしょうに
全然何の危険もなくて簡単に潰せますでしょ
しかし 自分の免疫システムがなくなったら
あの これは皆様もご存知だと思いますけど
この移植手術とかしたりする場合は
免疫機能全部ストップさせるんです
体の その時は その患者さんをビニールシートの中でビニールシートじゃなくて無菌室で入れておくんです
外の空気 触れないようにします
空気さえも無菌室で作っている
何の細菌入ってない空気を吸わなくちゃいけないんです
だから 看護師さんからみんな全部手袋やらなんだらかんだら全部特殊な人に触れないんです
免疫システムストップしたら大変なんですよ
あるいは薬で止めますから
薬を止めたらまた復活しますけど
まあそれで死ぬわけじゃないんです
だから心臓移植する場合は
心臓が体に体が受け止めるまで免疫システムもまずストップする
それから低下させる それで新しい心臓が体を受け取ったなとわかると
どんどん薬を減らして普通にしてあげるんです
で 慢の仕事はこんなもんなんです
慢は心の悪に対する抵抗力をなくすんです
我々は悪に対して抵抗力を持ってるんです
面白いね なんかいろいろものあるんですね
なんか悪はやりたくてたまらんだけど
どこかで抵抗力もあるんです
やりたくないと このやりたくないという抵抗力は慢を壊すんです
免疫システムを壊すんです
それでも知ったことじゃないんです
これで悪に対する抵抗力っていうのは知ってますか？あの
あれ 何でしたっけ 慚愧ですね
2つあります 慚と愧 切り寄った
生命は自殺することはありえないことです
しかし 慢が度を越したら
何の徴候もなく自殺をはかるんです
生命っていうのは自殺するっていうことは変ですよ
ありえないんです だって自己愛あるでしょうに
自分が一番高く評価しているでしょう
自殺は不可能です なのやっちゃうでしょ
これはどんな風に起こるかというと
この慢が混乱しちゃって
無知を強化するんですね
これで抵抗力がなくなるんです
それで自殺も可能です
自殺は怒りですよ 怒りっていうのは他殺でしょうね
人は殺したいんです いえ
自分を殺したいと そこまででも大きくなるんです
そのように慢は人の人生に影響を与えるんです
なんかアメリカのCIAみたいな感じなんです
慢は人生に 元に戻ったっけ
慢によって理性が失う
イコール無知の強化ですね
理性を失うということは
イコールありのままに物事を観察できない
ものを見えなくなっちゃうんですね
慢が入っちゃうと 理性を失うということは
無明の強化でもあり ありのままに見えないことでもあり
は全部同義語なんですね  「
それから間接的にすべての能力を低下する
それから慢さんが間接的に一切の能力を低下させます
喋る能力も 勉強する能力も
記憶する能力も 体力も
何でも低下させます 意欲が失います
薄になります 慢が入ってくると
感情は嵐のように働くんです
慢が入ってくると 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみの感情が頭の中で嵐になるんです
理性がないとは 柔軟性がないことでもあり
頑固であることですね
だから慢が入ってくると
慢は何もしない その代わりに無知無知を強化する
それで理性がなくなる
理性がなくなったということは
頑固になったということです
柔軟性もなくなったということなんです
慢は度を越すとブッダにも治療不可能になります
慢がちょっと失敗していると
仏教でも助けることはできないんです
お釈迦様が来ても 度を越している場合はもうダメです
慢が本能でアイデンティティでもあるならば
最終解脱に達するまで隙間と
まとうならば 人はどうすればいいのでしょうか？と
成人病など治療しても治らない病気にかかったらどうします？病気と巧みに付き合うんです
ね 治らないでしょ 解脱に達するまで
慢と巧みに付き合うんです
今教えてきましたからね
どうやって付き合うのかと
で 慢はなんていうか 逆手に取るんです
慢を逆手に取る方法があります
慢があっても理性を保つ
まず 例えば 人が自分のプライドを傷つくでしょ
傷ついたっても まあでも理性と理性を保つんです
興奮しないことにすると
それで お前私のプライドを傷ついただろうと言って何か対応できます
で 理性を保つんです 理性を失ったら自分が惨めになる
恥をかく みっともない
かっこ悪いと思うようになったら
それも慢ですが 自分を支えてくれます
こうしてください 例えば慢が出てくると
理性で傲慢あったらみっともないや
かっこ悪いんだ 惨めやと
人と喧嘩したらかっこ悪い
惨め ダサいと思ったら慢がコントロールできますね
しかし それも慢なんです
ダサいとかっこ悪いと思うことも
慢なんですけど これでなんかおかしいんですよ
ちゃんと慢を制しているんです
かっこ悪いと思った人は怒鳴ったりもしない
こんなかっこ悪いことしませんと
でも向こう側からいろいろ言われてるでしょうねと
まあ言われているんだけど
やっぱりかっこ悪いんだからね
よしましょうと言って
自分は慢で自分を守ってもらいます
善悪を区別 善悪の区別を明確にして
この応ではなくて それから善悪の区別をはっきりしてください
これが悪い これが良しと良いとはっきりしてほしい
自分のプライドをバネにして善を行う
俺がプライド高いんだと
だから悪いことなら絶対しませんよと
これは悪いことでしょうねと
私はやりませんよと たとえあんたにいくら言ったってのも
なんで俺がプライド高いだと
こんなみっともないことはしませんよというふうに
プライド慢をしっかり持つんです
この慢なくせないでしょうに
なくせない慢をしっかり持ってしっかりした人間になるんです
そのために必要なのは
善悪 善し悪しをしっかりしてほしいんです
それだけ  迷惑じゃなくて誘惑される時
自分の慢で自分を守るんです
結構誘惑されるでしょ？いろんな悪いことにズルズルといっちゃうでしょ
あれって卑下慢ですね
いけなかったら 行かなかったらまずいとか
卑下慢はダメです 高慢でないと
俺が行くもんかいと あんたみたいな人に誘惑されてもね
やらないものはやりませんよというふうにすれば
自分を守ってもらえます
道徳的 理性的 知恵がある優れた人を見て比較して
自分が劣っていると気づく
もう一つ 慢の使い方 すごく理性的で道徳的で優れてる人間
本当にいるでしょ 頭が良くて
性格も良くて 人類のためにいろんなことを素晴らしいことをする立派な人々いるでしょうに
その人々を見て卑下慢になってほしいんです
俺って何やと その人に等しくなる努力をするんです
だから偉い人に等しくなってやろうと頑張るんです
しかし 選んだ偉い人は本物です
本当にいい人なんです
それで この偉い人と等しくなろうっていうのは
道徳 慢の十二の二番目なんです
使っちゃえば正しく 無知な人
道徳感がない人を見て
また比較する それで無知な人も見えるでしょ
道徳は守らないわ 愛中であるわ
あれやこれやとかね そういう人を見たら
このように絶対になりたくないと行動する
それは高慢なんです こいつらとは仲間には絶対になりませんよと
相当な高慢でしょ これでOKです
善人の仲間になっているならば
そこから落ちないように努力する
はい たまたま皆様方 良い人々の仲間にグループに入れてもらう時ありますね
まあ時々はまあ今回だけいいよとかね
その時頑張って このグループとずっと一緒にしなくちゃあかんやと
と頑張れば それは同等慢を使うことなんです
この善人のグループからは落とされないようにしますよと
仲間外れにされないようにしますよと
しかし この仲間を理想で理性で選んでください
誰でも仲間じゃなくて
良い人が仲間なんです
そのように結構慢を使えますよ
自分の慢の焦点を善に合わせれば
慢が自分を育ててくれます
だから慢の焦点を善に合わせるだけです
自己破壊するところまで人を陥れる慢を巧みに使用すれば
解脱に達するまで応援してくれる衝動にもなるんです
一体慢って何ですかね？それで
慢って本当に分かりづらいやつですよ
で 人を自己破壊にまで陥れるんです
巧みに使えば 解脱にまで解脱に達するまで応援するんです
それが慢というものなんです
慢を持って慢を制するということなんです
だから仏教ではね 怒りを持って怒りを制するとは言わないんです
これは言います 慢を持って慢を制すると
日本でいうと 毒を持って何とか毒を制するとかね
それはないんです 慢を持って慢を制します
はい 経典からアーナンダ尊者がある比丘尼に語った経典なんですね
エピソードがあります
この比丘尼がね アーナンダ尊者に恋をしちゃったんですね
恋をしちゃっても叶わない恋だから
何とかしようとか結構企んじゃうんですね
それでどういう企みというと
病気に化けぼえになっちゃったんで
化けぼえになって もう寝たベッドに寝て
頭から衣をかぶって寝ているんですね
それで他の尼さんたちがね
どうなったのかといったら
すごい病気で まあしょうがない
もうアーナンダ尊者には何とか会いたいんだと
言ったら もしかするとこの人の最後かもしれませんと思ってね
他の比丘尼たちはだったらいいでしょうと言って
わさわさと空を仰いで
アーナンダというのはすごい偉いでしょうに
お釈迦様の側近で仕事をしなくちゃいけないでしょう
に 阿羅漢に悟ってなかったんですけど
ものすごい偉いでしょうね
アーナンダ尊者に言ったら
ある比丘尼がすごく病気になって倒れて
アーナンダ尊者に会いたいと言ってますから
もしやったらなんとかなるんじゃないかなと言ったら
あ そうですかと言ってアーナンダ尊者が行ったんです
行ったら アーナンダ尊者に立って礼をすることも何ともなく
えらい頭から体からもう寝ているんですね
アーナンダ尊者が これは怪しいと
この女はと すぐわかった
これはもう仮病だと それで説法したんです
この説法の一行だけ マナサンブートアヤンバギニカーヨ
マナンニッサーエ マノパハタブ
妹よ この体は慢によって構成されているのです
その慢をよりどころにして慢をなくすのですと
この説明あります その意味は何でしょうか
あなたにこのような情報が入ります
ある比丘は精神努力して
一切の煩悩を断って 真解脱・永解脱に達して
この世で一切の苦しみを乗り越えているのだという情報が入ります
いわゆる誰かが完全に悟ったんだという情報が入ります
帰ったらキマンガパナーハンと思ってくださいと
これはなかなか大変なパーリ語で
見たらどうったことない単語なんですけど
あれは現実的に同時に人々が喋っていたスラングなんですね
だから訳できないんです
辞書を引いたら何のこともない単語なんです
しかし 翻訳できないんです
これは当時で実際使ったスラングです
英語で Why not me?という意味なんですね
英語のスラングで Why me?というスラングがありまして
Why not me?という 2つあります
だからどちらでもスラングで
だから Why not me?っていうのは
なんで私にできないのかと
できるはずだろうと 私にできる
できないはずがないよということなんです Why
not me は そういうふうに思いなさいよと
あと その人はあの慢をよりどころにして慢を足すのですと
そこでえらい高慢ではなくて
その場合は は まあ偉い人と等しくなりたいという慢ですね
あの人が悟ったんですかね
俺もやってやると なんだ
あの人にできたならば
という感じで慢を使うんです
お釈迦様もアーラーラーカーラーもウッダカーラもプット両善人のところで似たような考えを起こして
初めて高度な禅定に達したと記してあります
このお釈迦様も相当慢でしょう
だって釈尊でしょうし
王子でしょうし ものすごい高慢だと思いますよ
だから釈迦族はそのもの高慢の塊であるとずっと言っているんです
高慢にしたら釈尊にはかなわないんだと
それぐらいたちが悪いんです
あの民族は お釈迦様の
しかし とても立派です
慢があるんだからこそ
やることはやるんです
慢で失敗しません 慢を叩くとゴールに達するまでめげない人間になってしまうんです
慢をもういじった方がいいんです
立ち上がれと そう なんてという感じで
お釈迦さんはそうなんです
できないはずがないんだと
慢をもいじるんですね
いじったら頑張れるんです
頑張ってゴールに達するんです
解脱と もう時間は過ぎましたね
そうですよね これは本当の経典の話です
あの まあ時間ないんです
読むだけだったら出しますけど
読んでもわからないでしょう
もう一つあったっけ はいはい
あの慢の関係ね まあなかなか慢は消えませんね
あの煩悩は受結といってね
10種類ありまして 下分結五と上分結五と分けて
上分結というのはルーパラガ
アルーパラガ マーナ ウッダッチャ
アヴィッチャーナなんですね
そこで阿羅漢果で上分所分結がなくなるんです
この阿羅漢まで残る慢というのは
よく見るとこの上級レベルの無知なんですね
難しいだからもう飛ばしましょう
私にとっては一番簡単に説明できるところなんですが
残念です このあの やっぱりこの慢があるんだから情けないではないんです
聖者は聖者なんです あの悟ったところで
慢がもうなかなか仕事できんだから
俺は休むぞと 休むんです
休むと無明になかなか強化できないんですね
慢がいないんだから これで第一預流果に悟っても
必ず最終解脱まで行きます
で そういうことだから
人格者なんですね だからだらしないこととか
それはまるっきりあり得ません
それからタンハー マーナ
渇愛 慢 無明っていうのは存在を築く根本的な働きですね
自我 エゴ 霊魂 魂という気持ちは全くありませんね
悟った人には しかし 自分がいるという実感があります
それに慢と呼ぶんです
このタンハー マーナ アヴィッチャーという 3つ
渇愛 慢 無明 これは悟るまでついてきます
完全に悟るまでついてきます
生きているんだから 阿羅漢になったらすぐもう涅槃に入るんですね
だからこの 3つなくなったら
肉体が植物としてある時間だけ生きているんです
それで終わり ですから
阿羅漢になる前はまだまだこの 3つは残っているんだという話です
しかし 自分がいるという実感があるんです
それを慢というんです
さらに修行しなくてはならないと知っているんです
本当に喜びに去った人は
俺が誘うとはなくて やっぱりもっともっと頑張らなくちゃ
まだまだありますよということをよく知っています
だから 慢はそういうふうに働くんです
解脱と悪を犯す俗世間に戻る煩悩がないので
のんびり落ち着いている可能性ありますよね
第一 二 三に悟ると 結構のんびりになっちゃうんです
不還果は確実に梵天に生まれるので
死も気にしないんです
だから なんかなんかあなた早く悟りに阿羅漢になってくださいったって
まあそのうちやってみますという気分なんです
全然心配しないんですね
だって自分が死んじゃったら梵天に生まれることは確実でしょうに
だから死に死のことも全然気にしない
この世があなた悟るんだと言ってるんですね
そういうことで この慢と慢というのは
あの 何て言いますか 自我自我意識じゃなくて
自分が生きているんだっていう実感ですからね
それだけなんです それがついてきます
情分結の力は 力と正邪を梵天に転生させる程度です
それからこの煩悩といったっても
情分結って ５つの煩悩があるでしょ
煩悩ってのは悪いことするでしょ
しかし この煩悩でできる悪いことというのは
死んだ人は梵天に生まれ変わる
生まれ変わるようにすることで
それだけです それ以上能力はないんです
相当な能力なんですよ
我々死んじゃったら地獄ですからね
この煩悩５つだけだったらもう梵天に生まれるんです
だから煩悩にしたっても
危機感はなくなっちゃうんですね
悪さはしませんね  そんなところかな
結論 慢は存在感そのものなので
簡単には立ちません 覚えてください
他の煩悩と組み合わせると慢は危険です
慢そのものがもうどうったことないんです
こいつら仲間組むんだから
仲間組めないようにしておかなくちゃいけないんです
慢は反乱しないように制御するんです
巧みに使えば役に立ちます
無常苦無我に納得しているならば
常に慈悲の実践がか気づきがあれば
慢は問題を起こしません
だから常に慈悲の瞑想をしているならば
慢は反乱を起こしません
かえって慢は巧みに使えるようになります
あるいは気づく 気づくというヴィパッサナーですね
やってると慢が全然問題を起こしません
まず終わりです はい どうもありがとうございます
すいません 時間がギリギリになってしまいましたので
質疑応答は割愛したいと思います
最後には皆さんで回向のして終了したいと思います
鑑賞してください 回向の
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナーの修行をやって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩が消えますように
サッビーティヨ ウィワンジャントゥ サッバローヴォ ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワットワンタラーヨ スキーディーガー ユコー バワ
ボウドゥ サッバ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバ デワター サッバ ブンターヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テア
アビワーダナ シーリスー ニッチャン ワッダー パチャヤーイノー チャッターロー ダンマー ワッダンティー アユーワンノー スカン バラン
はい どうもありがとうございます